(rock music)
- Welcome to the Jeselnik
and Rosenthal Vanity Project.
- JRVP
- [Woman] Junior Vice President.
- Two and a half years
later true love rises again.
- You think you watched
football last weekend?
Then you're a damn fool,
you watched nothing.
The season stars now.
- Right where we're
taping this in Hollywood,
Bernstein High, the Los Angeles Times
reporting that allegations
that two students
at the high school spiked
their high school team's water
at a junior varsity football practice
with a male enhancement drug
has prompted an investigation
that led to the dismissal of
varsity coach Luis Barajas.
- Now Greg, when they
say male enhancement,
I know you've got a little bit
of everything back at your home,
do you know which one it was
and what are the effects?
- They didn't specify, I mean,
I would assume it was a
Viagra or Cialis like product.
They did not even find evidence
that the students actually
drank the contaminated water.
They spoke to some doctors
who said they would really
need to know how much you drank
of this male enhancement product
to know what the effects could
be on a high school student
but I think we could all imagine.
- Here's what I'll say, okay,
and this should be common sense.
First of all, this was junior varsity team
and in the JV anything goes.
Secondly, how do you know if a bunch of
13 and 14 year olds have taken Viagra?
That's like a placebo
for a 14 year old boy.
We're talking Flintstone
vitamin level uselessness
to a 14 year old boy,
and they put it in the
water during practice.
Listen, if you love the game
the way my father loved the game
and my grandfather loved the game
then you practice with a full erection
or you sit in the sidelines flaccid.
Because you must be injured
if you're not running sprints in full pads
with all the blood in your penis.
God damn, PC culture is ruining the game.
- I don't even get to
follow up on the fact
that you're dad and grandfather
used to play football
with a full on erection.
- They played against each other
so we heard all the stories.
I don't know how it worked
out, but yeah, full blown.
Like, they started to wear cups
just so you wouldn't be able to find out
if they had the erection or not.
So then you could like, I'm
okay to go in the game coach
kinda thing, you know, like--
- What were Thanksgivings like
in the backyard of the Jeselnik household?
- I mean, it was fun,
we didn't play football.
We just kind of just sat around
and kind of like threw the football around
with erections.
(rock music)